STARTED WITH TWO DAYS BUT IT'S
UP BY PAIRING COUNTY. THE
SURPLUS WARM PLEASE FEDERAL.
FIRST YEAR HERE JONES SAWYER
LACKEY STONE CALAVERAS. THANK
YOU I HAVE BEEN ASKED TO READ
FROM THE RECTUS REGARDING
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION IN TODAY'S
HEARING TO HELP INSURE THE
SAFETY OF EVERYONE HERE TODAY
WELL ALLOWING FOR FULL PUBLIC
ACCESS TO THE DISCUSSION. TO
THEIR ROOM FOR THIRTY SEVEN WHO
ARE HAVING TO PHYSICALLY
DISTANT AND PERSON HEARING. CAN
ONLY ACCOMMODATE A FEW MEMBERS
A MINIMAL CONTENT TO THE STAFF
AND A LIMITED NUMBER. OF THE
PUBLIC AND MEDIA SO WE CAN KEEP
SIX FEET OF SPACING. THEY'RE
ALSO STRICT PHYSICAL THE THING
PROTOCOLS FOR THE PUBLIC TO
ENTER AND LEAVE THE CAPITAL.
AND FOR THOSE HERE TODAY TO
MAKE PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. A REAL ESTATE
THIS ON PUBLIC COMMON AGAINST
BUT IF ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
IN THE ROOM WISHES TO SPEAK
THEY WILL RAISE THEIR HANDS AND
I WILL ASK THEM TO PUT THE
MICROPHONE. WILL ALSO HAVE
PUBLIC COMMENT VIA TELEPHONE.
WE WILL HAVE PUBLIC COMMENT
AFTER WE'VE HEARD. ALL ITEMS ON
TODAY'S AGENDA. I WOULD AFFECT
THE PUBLIC RESPECT PHYSICAL
THIS NOTHING AND NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE YOU WILL HAVE ONE
MINUTE FOR PUBLIC COMMENT. YOU
CAN EXPECT TO HEAR ROOM ONCE
YOU'RE YOU'RE PUBLIC COMMUNIST
DONE OR RETURN TO USC PLEASE
OBSERVE PHYSICAL DISTANCE IN
UPON LEAVING THE CAPITAL.
INCLUDING LIMITING ELEVATOR
USED TO ONE PERSON AT A TIME.
THE PANELISTS L. A. ILL AND
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ARE
PAYING REMOTELY TODAY F. AND
EVERYONE SILENCE ELECTRONIC
DEVICES. AND PLEASE MAKE
YOURSELF WHEN YOU'RE NOT
SPEAKING. TODAY'S HEARING WILL
FOCUS ON A BOAT ONLY AGENDA
PROPOSAL FOR THE SUBCOMMITTEE
HAS HEARD IN PREVIOUS HEARINGS
AS WELL AS BRING ADJUSTMENTS IN
ADDITION WILL BE CARRY
MEDICINAL PROPOSALS. FROM THAT
WERE INTRODUCED IN THE SPRING
FROM VARIOUS DEPARTMENTS. AND
THE DISCUSSION ITEMS AFTER EACH
PANEL I WILL OPEN IT UP TO
SUBCOMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
QUESTIONS. OKAY SAYS WE HAVE A
QUORUM I'M GONNA GO AHEAD AND
START. TO DO SOME OF THE BUT
ONLY. ONE SECOND ROUND- YOU CAN
DO THE DISCUSSION FOR PEOPLE
HONESTLY. OKAY WAY FOR THE
RESTAURANT TO SHOP ACTUALLY IS
GO AHEAD AND THE DISCUSSION
WE'RE GONNA START WITH ISSUE
ONE FROM THE MILITARY
DEPARTMENT. YES THIS IS SALLY
GROUP IN BILL WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I'M HAPPY
TO SPEAK CALL AND PROVIDE AN
UPDATE ON THIS PROJECT TO DOING
VALLEY WON SECOND PLACE AND WE
FOR NOW IS GOING ON WITH OF ALL
THE- YES. SURE NO PROBLEM.
MAYBE YOU CAN AB CAN ALSO
INCREASE YOUR VOLUME ON YOUR
END. OR SPEAK LOUDER. COOL
THANK YOU THAT'S GREAT. IT IS
NOT BETTER OKAY PERFECT ALL
RIGHT- SO- TOPIC IS THE
MILITARY'S OF CONSOLIDATED
HEADQUARTERS COMPLEX PROJECT
PROJECT WAS FUNDED IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN AND SEVENTEEN
POOR PERFORMANCE CRITERIA AND
DESIGN BUILT FOR TOTAL
APPROPRIATIONS OF APPROXIMATELY
A HUNDRED TWENTY NINE MILLION.
SITS ON THIRTY ACRES AND RETRO
CORDOVA. REPORT ON THE PROPERTY
THIS PROJECT WAS ACQUIRED IN
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN. THE
PROJECT LARGEST INCLUDES THE
CONSTRUCTION OF TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY EIGHT THOUSAND SQUARE
FEET OF THE CONSOLIDATED
HEADQUARTERS FACILITY EACH ONE
THOUSAND SQUARE FOOT ARMORY.
ANY TWENTY TWO THOUSAND SQUARE
FOOT STORAGE FACILITY AND THE
COMPLEX WILL EVENTUALLY
CONSOLIDATE APPROXIMATELY A
THOUSAND EMPLOYEES CURRENTLY
WORKING OUT OF NUMEROUS FREE
SPACES BROCKTON. OF THIS
PROJECT HAS BEEN UNDER
CONSTRUCTION SINCE LATE TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN EARLY TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AND WE
RECENTLY BECAME AWARE OF
NUMEROUS CHALLENGES WITH THE
PROJECT. THAT HAVE BEEN GOING
ON FOR SOME TIME THAT HAVE
RESULTED IN SIGNIFICANT
CONSTRUCTION DELAYS. OF THESE
CHALLENGES INCLUDE-
COMMUNICATION BREAKDOWNS
BETWEEN MILITARY PROJECTS OUT
CONTRACTOR. INCONSISTENCIES
BETWEEN R. F. P. AND
CONSTRUCTION CONTRACT. VETERANS
WITH INSPECTION OVERSIGHT. WE
UNDESERVEDLY WILL BURN ON MARCH
NINETEENTH THE STATE FARM
MARSHALL ISSUED A STOP WORK
WORK ON THE PROJECT CITING
NUMEROUS IDENTIFIED
DEFICIENCIES THAT REMAIN
UNCORRECTED. SINCE THEY ARE
WORKING WITH PROJECT REMAIN
SUSPEND. IN THE PAST FEW WEEKS
WE'VE BEEN WORKING CLOSELY AND
IN DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
MILITARY ON HOW BEST TO GET
THIS PROJECT BACK ON TRACK. AND
WE COLLECTIVELY AGREE BEST
COURSE OF ACTION IS TO ENGAGE
IN EXPERTISE OF G. G. S. RATHER
THAN CONTINUE TO MANAGE. WHEN
OUR MILITARYPERSONNEL ONLY I'M
PETER IS ALREADY ASSIGNED FOR
THE PROJECT DIRECTOR OF THE
PROJECT AND THAT PROJECT
DIRECTOR HAS WALKED THE PROJECT
SITE IN ORDER TO ASSESS
BEEN IN CONTACT WITH THE STATE
COURT MARTIAL. ART WITH
ADDITION TO JUSTICE RECOMMENDED
CONTRACTING WITH THE
CONSTRUCTION SUPERVISOR AND A
THIRD PARTY CONSTRUCTION
MANAGEMENT FIRM TO RECONCILE
THE SCHEDULE AND WE'RE LIKE
WAIT OUTSTANDING SHIPPED ORDERS
ALSO SUGGESTED MILITARY ARE
CURRENTLY. MAKING EFFORTS TO
BRING A COPY. WE ARE CONFIDENT
THESE EFFORTS WILL COOK QUICKLY
GET THIS PROJECT BACK ON TRACK-
AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO
MONITOR. CLOSELY ON THE
PROGRESS OF THIS ALONG WITH
THAT I WOULD BE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU- THANK
YOU WE HAVE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. HE SORT OF
BORED WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE WE DON'T HAVE
ANY ANY ANY ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION TO PROVIDE BETTER
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THAT WE CAN. THANK YOU FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DO YOU
HAVE ANY SENSE OF. ANY
INCREASED COSTS THAT ARE GOING
TO RESULT FROM THE CEILING.
WE'RE STILL ASSESSING NOT-
WE'RE WE'RE DETERMINING WHETHER
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT COULD BE
HANDLED ADMINISTRATIVELY ORDER
NEEDS TO BE A BUDGET US THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE WERE
ASSESSING AND WILL WILL. WITHIN
THE WEEK APPLE. HE SAID WITHIN
A WEEK. YES THEY HAVE THEIR
HELP YEAH I THINK IT WILL HAVE
A RARE PRECIADO LOOK FORWARD TO
THAT INFORMATION. THAT WE'RE
GOING TO HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN
TODAY THANK YOU. WE'LL GO AHEAD
AND MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER TWO.
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES.
MADAM CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
STANDARD OUT THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THANKS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TODAY
THE REQUESTED FOR THE COMMITTEE
IS THE TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENTS TO
ELIMINATE- BUT STILL FORTY FOR
TWO ITEMS WITHIN CALLAWAY HELLO
THIS IS BUDGET- WHICH NO LONGER
HAVE A DEDICATED REVENUE
SOURCE- SB SEVENTY TWO OF
TWENTY FOURTEEN AND AB THIRTEEN
NINETY NINE OF TWENTY SIXTEEN
RESPECTIVELY OUT OF- FALTER
CONTRIBUTIONS- ON THE PERSONAL
INCOME TAX FORM. FOR TWO
VICTIMS SERVICES FUNDS. NEITHER
FONG- RECEIVED A MINIMUM- IN
ACCORDANCE WITH STATUTES- THE
PROVISIONS OF REVENUE AND
TAXATION CODE HAVE SINCE BEEN
REPEALED- REVENUE WAS NO
LONGER. BEING COLLECTED TO
MATCH THE EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY. WITHIN THE BUDGET
AND SO THIS CONFORMING ACTION
WHAT. IT LIMIT THE- A BUDGET
AUTHORITY- BECAUSE THERE'S NO
REVENUE- TO. THE PAPER THE-
EXPENDITURES- WITHOUT I AM
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
YES THANK YOU CAN YOU LET US
KNOW WHAT THE MINIMUM THRESHOLD
IS FOR- BUT THESE PLANS WITH
THE NOT ME. SURE SO- BOTH OF
THE BOTH OF THE BILLS LAID OUT
THE MINIMUM THRESHOLD EACH IS
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS- YOU PERSPECTIVE- FIND-
NEVER MET THAT AMOUNT IN. EACH
TAXABLE YEAR AND THEREFORE- HAS
SINCE BEEN REPEALED. WHAT
INCOME YOU SAID THAT'S NEVER
MET AT. IN THE IN ITS IN ITS
EXISTENCE THAT HAS NEVER MET
THE THRESHOLD. THAT IS CORRECT
WITHIN EACH TAXABLE YEAR. OKAY
THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE MEMBERS.
OKAY THANK YOU WE'RE GOING TO
HOLD THAT ITEM OPEN AS WELL.
THANK YOU. OUR ISSUE. OKAY
ARENA HERE NEXT FROM THE
CALIFORNIA LAW REVISION
COMMISSION ISSUE NUMBER THREE
WE HAVE TWO PANELIST. FOR
MORNING MY NAME IS MICHAEL
ROMANO I'M THE CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE IN THE REVISION OF
THE PENAL CODE. CARMICHAEL HI
THANK YOU FOR CONSIDERING A
REQUEST- THIS IS I'M SORRY THIS
VIDEO COMING THROUGH OKAY. JEFF
RIGHT THE I THINK WE'RE HERE TO
FOLLOW UP ON A BUDGET REQUEST
TO INCREASE OUR STAFF- THINK-
MODESTLY- AS YOU AS YOU MAY
KNOW WE ARE CURRENTLY- TIED TO
THE COMMISSION THE LAW REVIEW
COMMISSION BUT THE PENAL CODE
COMMITTEE IS A SEPARATE ENTITY
WE ARE SHARE STAFF AND- THIS IS
BEEN A PROPOSAL TO EXPAND THE
COMMITTEE ESSENTIALLY TO MATCH
THE NUMBER OF ATTORNEYS THAT
ARE IN THAT THE COMMISSION AND
TO BRING US INTO A COHORT THAT
WE COULD ESSENTIALLY BEGIN TO
STAND ON OUR OWN RATHER THAN TO
BE DEPENDED UPON. ATTORNEYS
FROM THE COMMISSION I'M HAPPY
TO EXPLAIN FURTHER ANSWER ANY
QUETIONS YOU MAY HAVE. THANK
YOU WE ALSO HAVE THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE. I
NEED ONLY WITH THE L. A. L. WE
HAVE NO CONCERNS WITH THIS
PROPOSAL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND- I DON'T HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
TO THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS ON THE
FEDERAL. RIGHT THEN. IN THAT
CASE- ERR PRECIADO EVERYONE AND
WE'RE GOING TO HOLD THIS ITEM
OPEN AS WELL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
OKAY. MOVING ON WE HAVE THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE FOR ISSUE
NUMBER FOUR. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR CHRIS RYAN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE. AND OUR
SPRING FINANCE LETTERS TODAY-
THERE'S TWO SPRING FINANCE
LETTERS THAT WE HAVE- THE FIRST
ONE IS RELATED TO THE BUREAU OF
GAMBLING CONTROL. AND THIS IS A
REQUEST RELATED TO- POSITIONS-
THEY WERE PREVIOUSLY WHERE
THIRTY TWO LONGER TERM
POSITIONS WITHIN THE BUREAU
THIS REQUESTIS FOR A TWENTY
PER TO MAKE TWENTY OF THOSE
POSITIONS PERMANENT ON THE
TOTAL REQUEST IS FOR THREE
POINT FOUR MILLION DOLLARS- IT
ALSO. INCLUDES ADDITIONAL
CLERICAL OR SUPPORT- FOR THE
WORKLOAD ON THE PIER OF
GAMBLING CONTROL WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT JUSTICE IS THE STATE
LAW ENFORCEMENT AUTHORITY- WITH
SPECIFIC JURISDICTION OVER
GAMBLING ACTIVITIES IN
CALIFORNIA- I DO HAVE- YOLANDA
MORROW AVAILABLE TODAY IF WE
HAVE QUESTIONS ON THIS
PROPOSAL- ESSENTIALLY AGAIN
JUST WANNA REPEAT THIS IS A
PROPOSAL. TO ADDRESS A LIMITED
TERM POSITIONS FROM PREVIOUS
YEARS- THAT WERE AT THIRTY TWO
NOW BEING PROPOSED AT TWENTY
POSITIONS THE NEXT PROPOSAL
THAT WE HAVE. IS FOR THE
DIVISION OF MEDICAL FRAUD AND
ELDER ABUSE- THIS IS A PROPOSAL
FOR POSSIBLY THIRTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS- PRIMARILY A TECHNICAL
REQUEST TO DRAW DOWN MORE
FEDERAL FUNDS- TO- AND MATCHED
WITH STATE STATE FUNDS- IN A
7525% RATIO. AND I HAVE-
JENNIFER YOU ARE AVAILABLE- IF
THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT OUR
ACTIVITIES IN THE DIVISION OF
MEDICARE. FRAUD ELDER ABUSE SO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WE HAVE
THE BUREAU OF GAMBLING CONTROL
ALSO. THEY ARE HERE AVAILABLE
IF THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS- SO WE
HAVE- YOLANDA MORALE IS
AVAILABLE AND THE- CHIEF
ASSISTANT ATTORNEY GENERAL.
JENNIFER IS ALSO HERE TO FOR
QUESTIONS YES AND SHE'S HERE
JENNIFER HILLER IS HERE FOR THE
MEDICAL FRAUD AND ELDER ABUSE
QUESTIONS OKAY THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE THAT AND THEN WE
HAVE THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE- IDEALLY WITH THE L. A-
WE DON'T HAVE ANY CONCERNS THAT
THE PROPOSAL'S BUT ARE
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY. THANK
YOUNG. THANK YOU HAVE A
QUESTION FOR THE BUREAU OF
GAMBLING CONTROL- BASED ON THE
PREVIOUS AUDIT WHERE ARE YOU AT
IN IMPLEMENTING THE
RECOMMENDATIONS. I'M GOOD
MORNING DONNA MORROW AND THE
BUREAU OF GAMBLING CONTROL
TARGET AFTERNOON I'M ALL OF
THEIR AUDIT RECOMMENDATIONS
RELATED TO THE BACKGROUND OF
THE ASIAN PROCESS HAPPEN FULLY
IMPLEMENTED I AM ALL BUT ONE OF
THOSE WERE IMPLEMENTED BY THE
END OF TWENTY NINETEEN OF THE
LAST ONE WAS IMPLEMENTED- IN
MARCH OF TWENTY TWENTY. THERE
ARE STILL THREE OUTSTANDING- I
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT HAVE NOT
BEEN IMPLEMENTED- BUT NONE OF
THOSE RELATE SPECIFICALLY TO
THE BACK ON A RECITATION. AND
THEIR PROGRESS ARE COMING FOR
THE REMAINING ITEMS. AND WE ARE
WORKING TO IMPLEMENT THOSE AND-
I ONE OF THEM IS GOING TO
REQUIRE ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO
UPGRADE THE SYSTEM AND IN ORDER
TO TIME TRACK. AND ANOTHER ONE
IS RELATED TO A COST ANALYSIS
CALIFORNIA GAMBLING CONTROL
COMMISSION AND A CONSULTANT AND
THAT'S NEARING A CONCLUSION AND
THE LAST ONE AND- IS. IN
REGARDS TO OUTSTANDING GAME
APPROVALS. WORKING OF THE
REGULATIONS REGARDING THAT.
THANK YOU- AND THEN ALSO FOR.
THE WITH THE BUREAU OF GAMBLING
CONTROL FOR THESE POSITIONS
WERE ORIGINALLY PROVIDED ON A
TEMPORARY BASIS TO ADDRESS THE
BACKLOG. AND SO CAN YOU LET US
KNOW WHERE YOU'RE AT WITH THE
BACKLOG AND- I GUESS
JUSTIFICATION FOR MAKING THESE
TEMPORARY POSITIONS PERMANENT.
OF COURSE JUST TO GET SOME
BACKGROUND AND IN FIFTEEN
SIXTEEN THE BUREAU IDENTIFIED A
BACKLOG OF TWO THOUSAND TWO
HUNDRED AND TWENTY ONE. I THINK
HE SAID. AT THIRTY TWO
POSITIONS WERE ESSENTIAL AND
VITAL IN- ASSISTING IN REDUCING
THAT BACKLOG SO I THINK MARCH
OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE
BACKLOG IS AT FORTY EIGHT HE
SAID. I'M TWENTY TWO OF THOSE
ARE MORE COMPLEX INVESTIGATIONS
OF OWNERS AND I'M BUSINESSES
THAT TYPICALLY TAKE LONGER THAN
SIX MONTHS TO COMPLETE. I
HOWEVER NOW THAT THE CARDS HAVE
REOPENED- AND SOME OF THE FOR
LOW CARBON PLEASE ARE BACK TO
WORK- WE ARE. HOPEFUL THAT
THOSE FORTY REPEATING LOOKING.
THEY DID VERY. THANK YOU FOR
THE UPDATE ON THE BACKLOG AND
THE PROGRESS THAT HAS BEEN
MADE. IN THESE POSITIONS WERE
TEMPORARILY. GRANTED AND NOW
THEY'RE BEING ASKED TO BE
PERMANENT POSITIONS CAN YOU
EXPLAIN TO US. THE NEED OR THE
JUSTIFICATION OF THE BACKLOG IS
ALMOST DONE. ABSOLUTELY AND IN
THE THREE POTS WERE ACTUALLY
ASKING FOR LAST IT WAS THE
VISION SO TWENTY OF THE THIRTY
TWO ANALYST POSITIONS FOR THE
ONGOING WORK. THAT IS BASED ON
A FIVE YEAR AVERAGE INCOMING
APPLICATIONS. AND SO EVEN
THOUGH THE BACKLOG HAS BEEN
REDUCED EASY TWENTY ANALYST
POSITIONS ARE NEEDED IT JUST TO
ENSURE ADAM WHAT'S CONTINUE OUR
PROGRESS AND TO ENSURE THAT
ADDITIONAL BACKLOG DOESN'T
ACCRUE- I'M GOING INTO THE
KITCHEN AND SIX OF THE
POSITIONS. THAT WERE REQUESTING
THAT MAKE UP THE TWENTY SIX
TOTAL POSITION WOULD BE
CLERICAL POSITIONS THAT WILL
ASSIST US IN TAKING SOME OF THE
WORK OFF THE BACKGROUND
INVESTIGATION I'M SO
THEY CAN FOCUS ON THIS
BACKGROUND AND ENSURE BACKLOG.
DOESN'T APPROVE. EACH AND SO
THERE. A UP MY LEFT ON
UNDERSIDE. THEY'RE ALL DO YOU
HAVE ANY VACANCIES THAT YOU.
THAT ARE PROMINENT POSITIONS
THAT YOU NEED TO FILL IN
ADDITION TO THE STATE THAT
YOU'RE ASKING. AND SOME OF THE
VACANCIES- I BELIEVE SOE
VACANCIES WERE NOTED IN A
LETTER THAT WAS SENT TO YOU I'M
MANY OF THOSE VACANCIES ARE ON
THE- AND- SPECIAL AGENT ARM
SIDE AND THE AUDITOR SITE WHICH
ARE HISTORICALLY DIFFICULT
RECRUITS. THERE ARE SOME BEGIN
ANALYST POSITIONS HOWEVER-
SINCE THE BUREAU IS AWARE THAT
WE WERE REQUESTING LESS- THAT
WERE PREVIOUSLY PREDICTED. AND
THIS POSITION PRICE ACTUALLY
HELP MAKE IT SO THAT IT THIS
REQUEST IS APPROVED OR NOT.
STATE ANY CURRENT EMPLOYEES.
CAN YOU EXPLAIN THAT TO ME
AGAIN I APOLOGIZE FOR THAT BUT
RATIONALE- OKAY AND WE WERE.
APPROVED OR CURRENTLY APPROVED
FOR THIRTY TWO POSITIONS-
ANALYST POSITION HOWEVER
REQUESTING TWENTY I'M GOING.
AND SO THAT'S TWELVE LACK
PHYSICIANS THAT WE PREVIOUSLY
BEEN OPERATES FOR I'M SO IN
ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PERMANENT STOCK OR THAT. STOCK
THAT WE HAVE CURRENTLY EMPLOYED
AND HAVE ANALYST AT THIS IS TO
GO TO ONCE WE ELIMINATE THOSE
TWELFTH THE VACANCIES WILL BE
TAKEN BY- EXISTING STAFF SO
THEY WON'T BE DISPLACED. SO
YOU'RE BASICALLY ARE TELLING ME
THAT ALL OF THE TEMPORARY
POSITIONS YOU'RE- EITHER FIND A
SPOT FOR THEM OR TRYING TO
CREATE A PROMESAS A SPOT FOR
THEM. CORRECT. QUESTIONS FROM
THE MEMBERS. ISRAEL OUT OF- YET
AGAIN JUST TO CLARIFY CLARIFY
THE VACANCIES IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THERE'S
APPROXIMATELY THIRTY EIGHT
VACANCIES POR PER YEAR BUT- YOU
JUST SAID THAT THE MAJORITY OF
THESE VACANCIES ARE AGENTS OR
AUDITORS SO I'M I'M JUST
CONFUSED AS- IF WHO ARE YOU
MOVING OVER- PEOPLE WHO DON'T
WANT TO DISPLACE INTO AGENT
ROLES- AUDITOR ROLES. NOW I'M
SORRY LET ME CLARIFY EIGHT
CURRENTLY THERE ARE EIGHTEEN
VACANCIES IN THE LICENSING
SECTION I AM THIS REPORT IS
REQUESTING TWELVE LEFT THE
VISION THAT WE'RE CURRENTLY
OPERATES FOUR. SO THAT IS WHERE
THE ANALYST- WILL GO INTO
THOSE- EIGHTEEN MAKE IT THESE
ARE SOME OF THOSE EIGHTEEN
VACANCY S. WE WILL ULTIMATELY
SIX THE VICTIMS BECAUSE REQUEST-
IT'S REDUCING THE NUMBER OF
STOCK IN A LICENSING SECTION.
OKAY THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS. OKAY ARE WE GONNA GO
AHEAD AND HOLD THAT ITEM. OPEN.
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER FIVE THE BOARD OF STATE
AND COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE CAN
YOU HEAR ME ALRIGHT. IF YOU
COULD SPEAK UP IT'S KINDA LOW-
OKAY LET ME CHECK MY VOLUME.
OKAY IS THAT BETTER. YEAH THAT
THAT'S BETTER OKAY THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS KATIE
HOWARD AND I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE BOARD OF STATE
AND COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS WE'RE
HERE TODAY TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION ON THE SPRING
FINANCE LETTER PC PETE THAT'S
CONNECTED TO OUR WORK ON-
FACILITY COUNTY FACILITY
INSPECTIONS WE SPOKE WITH THIS
COMMITTEE AT SOME LENGTH IN THE
OF MARCH HEARING SO I WILL JUST
QUICKLY MOVED TO. GIVE YOU A
HIGH LEVEL SUMMARY OF WHAT IS
IN THIS B. C. P. WHERE OF
COURSE HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE-
THE B. C. P. PROPOSES FOURTEEN
POSITIONS TO STRENGTHEN
OVERSIGHT- OF COUNTY DETENTION
FACILITIES AND SO THAT'S EIGHT
ADDITIONAL INSPECTOR POSITIONS
AND SIX POSITIONS THAT ARE A
COMBINATION OF MANAGERS AND
ANALYSTS AND IN A VERY BRIEF
SUMMARY- WE ARE PROPOSING TO
INCREASE THE FREQUENCY OF
INSPECTIONS FROM ONCE OVER A
TWO YEAR CYCLE. TO ANNUAL
INSPECTIONS THERE'S A WHOLE LOT
MORE DETAIL THAT I COULD GO
INTO BUT THAT'S THE TOP LINE
SUMMARY AS YOU KNOW THE
GOVERNOR DIRECTED US IN JANUARY
OF TWENTY TWENTY TO STRENGTHEN
JAIL OVERSIGHT AND WE'RE VERY
VERY PLEASED THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS COME FORWARD
WITH THIS PROPOSAL THAT WILL
TRULY HELP TO MEET THE GOALS
THAT WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON OVER
THE LAST YEAR OF INCREASED
ACCOUNTABILITY MUCH MORE
FREQUENT INFORMATION AT OUR
PUBLIC BOARD MEETINGS- TO ALL
OF OUR BOARD MEMBERS AS WELL AS
OUR MANY STAKEHOLDERS ON WHAT
THE- ISSUES OF NON COMPLIANCE
CAR- AND IN ADDITION A WHOLE
LOT MORE- ACCOUNTABLE
INFORMATION. ABOUT OUT OF
COMPLIANCE ISSUES SO WITH THE
ADDITIONAL ANALYTICAL STAFF AND
IN MANAGEMENT STAFF AS WELL AS
A DATABASE THAT WERE IN THE
PROCESS OF BUILDING WE WILL BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE MORE REGULAR
INFORMATION ANALYZED TRENDS AND
REPORT OUT TO OUR BOARD AND THE
PUBLIC AND THE LEGISLATURE AND
ANYBODY WHO MIGHT BE INTERESTED
ON WHAT IS HAPPENING IN THESE-
JAIL AND JUVENILE DETENTION
INSPECTIONS. SO THAT IS- OF
VERY QUICK- SUMMARY THAT WERE-
WE HAVE A PROPOSAL THAT-
PROVIDES FOR STREAMLINED
PROCESS THESE AND SYSTEMS AND
STRENGTHENS OUR- INSPECTION
FUNCTION SO THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
HERE TO TALK ABOUT TODAY. THANK
YOUR OUR NEXT PANELIST. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS RENE MENOR
COMMUNICATIONS AND POLICY
ANALYST AT THE CENTER ON
JUVENILE AND CRIMINAL JUSTICE
TDCJ AND DOZENS OF OTHER
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
HAVE MONITORED THE BSE SEASONS
OF THE STOCK WHICH MEANT AND I
PERSONALLY ATTENDED NEARLY
EVERY BOARD MEETING IN THE LAST
THREE YEARS. WE'VE WITNESSED
THE BSE SEES FAILURES TO
PROTECT PEOPLE AND LOCAL
FACILITIES AND WE'VE SEEN THE
AGENCY'S RELUCTANCE TO CORRECT
COURSE TIME AND AGAIN. THESE
FAILURES HAVE BEEN HIGHLIGHTED
IN THE RECENT LA- REPORT AND
VARIOUS MEDIA INVESTIGATIONS.
THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL OFFERS
ONLY SUPERFICIAL ACTIONS THAT
ARE INSUFFICIENT TO ADDRESS THE
CONCERNS RAISED BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE LESS THAN TWO MONTHS
AGO. WHEN YOU LOOK CLOSELY AT
THIS PROPOSAL IT QUICKLY
BECOMES CLEAR THAT THE COST
ASSOCIATED WITH IT FALL INTO
CATEGORIES UNNECESSARY OR
PREMATURE WITHOUT DEEPER
REFORMS. THE PROPOSAL INCLUDES
A PLAN TO REPORT REGULARLY TO
THE SEC BOARD DIRECTING
AGENCIES TO APPEAR BEFORE THE
BOARD ON ISSUES OF NON
COMPLIANCE. THIS IS ALREADY A
BASIC RESPONSIBILITY OF THE BSE
SEE THAT SHOULD NOT COME AT AN
ADDITIONAL COST. WE AGREE WITH
EXPLICITLY GRANTING THE BSE C.
FORTY THE CARRY OUT UNANNOUNCED
INSPECTIONS WHICH CAN ALSO BE
IMPLEMENTED WITHOUT INCREASED
FUNDING. HOWEVER WE MUST ASK
THAT YOU REJECT THE REMAINDER
OF THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL. THE
PLANS TO CHANGE THE FREQUENCY
OF INSPECTIONS TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND REPORTING COM AT
INCREASED COSTS TO TAXPAYERS
WITHOUT PROMISE FOR
IMPROVEMENT. MORE INSPECTIONS
AND FOLLOW UP TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE WILL DO NOTHING TO
INCREASE PROTECTIONS PARKING
CARS READ LOVED ONES UNLESS THE
ACTUAL STANDARDS AND QUALITY OF
INSPECTIONS ARE VASTLY IMPROVED.
WITH THE BSEE'S DEMONSTRATED
RELUCTANCE TO HOLD COUNTIES
ACCOUNTABLE DOING INSPECTIONS
MORE FREQUENTLY WILL MERELY
CONTAIN THE STATUS QUO WE'RE
MAJOR HEALTH AND SAFETY HAZARDS
ARE SWEPT UNDER THE RUG.
STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS
SECRETARY CURRENT STATUTE
REQUIRES THAT THE BSE C. CARRY
OUT BIENNIAL INSPECTIONS THIS
PROPOSAL DOES NOT INCREASE THAT
REQUIREMENT IN FACT THIS
FLEXIBILITY BUILT INTO THE
PROPOSAL NOTING THAT FACILITIES
FOUND TO HAVE SIGNIFICANT
ISSUES QUOTE MIGHT RECEIVE
ANOTHER COMPREHENSIVE
INSPECTION. THIS IS
PARTICULARLY CONCERNING SINCE
THE PSEC TAKES A NARROW VIEW OF
ITS RESPONSIBILITIES AND USES
ITS DISCRETION TO ACT IN
SERVICE OF COUNTIES RATHER THAN
EFFECTIVE OVERSIGHT AND
TRANSPARENCY. THE PROPOSAL
ALLOWS THE AGENCY TO CONTINUE
TO USE ITS DISCRETION FOR HANDS
OFF APPROACH TO THE DETRIMENT
OF PEOPLE INCARCERATED INSIDE
LOCAL FACILITIES. IT'S WITH
THIS THAT WE MUST AGAIN ASK FOR
THE PROPOSAL TO BE REJECTED
EXCEPT FORGET GRANTING CLEAR
AUTHORITY FOR UNANNOUNCED
INSPECTIONS. THE FAILURE OF THE
BSE C. MUST BE ADDRESSED IN
RESTRUCTURING ITS LEADERSHIP AS
A FIRST AND IMMEDIATE STAFF.
ONGOING PROBLEMS AT THE AGENCY
ARE CAUSED BY STRUCTURAL
DEFICIENCIES INCLUDING FUNK
THERE OVERSIGHT GOALS AND
PROBLEMATIC LEADERSHIP. YES HE
SEES WITH CITY REGULATIONS AND
INSPECTIONS ARE FAILING DUE TO
AN AGENCY CULTURE THAT
PRIORITIZES CORRECTIONAL
PERSPECTIVES OVER BEST
PRACTICES. RIGHT NOW EIGHT
BOARD MEMBERS ARE CURRENT OR
FORMER LAW ENFORCEMENT-
CORRECTIONS STAFF AND FOR THOSE
BOARD MEMBERS ARE SUBJECT TO
INSPECTIONS. THE BSE SEAT NEEDS
TO BE INDEPENDENT OF THE
AGENCIES THAT THEY OVERSEE
BEFORE THE STATE BOLSTERS THEIR
SPENDING FOR STAFFING. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU THAT WE HAVE THE
L. A. L. OFFICE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR CAITLYN YOU KNOW
ALEJO. AND AS WAS MENTIONED WE
DID RELEASE A REPORT EARLIER
THIS SPRING ON THE DSCC
STANDARDS INSPECTIONS PROGRAM
THAT WAS HEARD BY THE SCHOOL ON
MARCH EIGHT. I'M JUST AS A
BRIEF OVERVIEW WE RECOMMENDED
THAT THE LEGISLATURE SAT
EXPLICIT GOALS FOR THE PROGRAM
AND STATUTES AS WELL AS A LINE
B. MEMBERSHIP THE BOARD
MEMBERSHIP WITH NO SCHOOLS AND
REQUIRE BE AS EASY TO SUBMIT A
PLAN TO THE LEGISLATURE FOR HOW
IT WILL- REDESIGNED THE PROGRAM
TO ACHIEVE. THAT GOAL WHATEVER
GOALS THAT IS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE. CHOOSES TO FACT. I
WE CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THAT
APPROACH AND THAT'S ABOUT IT TO
SPECIFIC PROPOSAL BEFORE YOU TO
DATE- WE THINK THAT IT TO THE
EXTENT THE LEGISLATURE DOES
WANT TO MOVE FORWARD WITH OUR
RECOMMENDED REFORMS WE THINK
THAT IT WOULD. BE PREMATURE TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL RESOURCES TO
BE A CC AT THIS POINT GIVEN
THAT- THE LEGISLATIVE ONCE ABBY
THE FCC SUBMITS ITS PLAN TO THE
LEGISLATURE FOR HAVE A LINE THE
PROGRAM WITH. WHATEVER GOALS
THE LEGISLATURE AT SECOND
STATUTE THE LEGISLATURE WOULD
BE IN A MUCH BETTER POSITION TO
RESOURCES ARE NEEDED-
ENSURE THAT THE SEC'S PROGRAM
CAN- CARRY OUT THOSE GOALS IN
THAT IT IS OPERATING IN A
MANNER THAT SUFFICIENT. AND
CONSISTENT WITH LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITIES. I'M THE OWNER TO
EXTENT THAT THE LEGISLATURE.
ATTITUDE NOT TO MOVE FORWARD
WITH OUR RECOMMENDED REFORMS-
WE WOULD ALSO RCOMMEND
REJECTING THE RESOURCES ARE
THERE THE REQUESTED STAFFING-
BECAUSE- WE THINK THAT IT
APPEARS THAT YOU KNOW BY AND
LARGE THE SEC HAS KIND OF
IMPLICITLY WELL DOESN'T HAVE
EXPLICIT FILED STATUTORY GOAL
CAN IMPLICITLY OPERATED- WITH
THE GOAL OF HELPING COUNTIES.
IDENTIFIED AND MEET LEGAL
REQUIREMENTS AND THAT IS ONE OF
THE FOUR GOALS THAT WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
ESTABLISHED FOR PSEC- THE DATE
CHANGES THATTHE FCC HAVE BEEN
MAKING OVER THE PAST YEAR IN
THE POOL AND THE PROPOSED-
BEFORE YOU AS WELL AS THE
RESOURCES BEING REQUESTED WOULD
LARGELY. GO TO SUPPORTING THIS
CALL AND NOT TO THE OTHER THREE
GOALS THAT WE RECOMMENDED-
WHICH FOR EXAMPLE WERE TO
PROVIDE INCREASED TRANSPARENCY-
AND ACCOUNTABILITY OR
FACILITATE ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY. FOUNDED TENSION
TO. AND SO WITH THAT SAID- WE
THINK THERE WE DISEASE HASN'T
BEEN ABLE TO PROVIDE US JUST TO
THE- THAT THERE IS A NEED TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
FOR THAT ONE PARTICULAR GOAL
OF- HELPING ME LOCAL DETENTION
FACILITIES AND DETERMINE MEET
LEGAL REQUIREMENTS IN OTHER
WORDS IT APPEARS THE PROPOSAL
WOULD LARGELY INCREASE THE
SERVICE LEVEL TO CITIES AND
COUNTIES BUT WE HAVEN'T HEARD.
ANY EVIDENCE FROM CITIES AND
COUNTIES ADJUSTING THE CURRENT
SERVICE SERVICE LEVEL IS
INADEQUATE SO WITHOUT REASON WE
WOULD REJECT THE PROPOSAL
RECOMMEND REJECTING EVEN IF ON
THE LEGISLATURE IS NOT
INTERESTED IN MOVING FORWARD
WITH OUR RECOMMENDED REFORMS-
AND THEN ONCE THAT FINAL NOTE
IS THAT THERE IS ARE TO COMPLY
OF THE PROPOSAL WE DO WORK
APPROVING ONE- A HUNDRED FIFTY.
THOUSAND DOLLARS I'M GOING. TO
BE A FIFTY TWO. ALLOW
INSPECTORS TO DATA. DURING
INSPECTION WHICH WE THINK DOES
MAKE SENSE- OUR LIST OF WHAT
IT'S THE LEGISLATURE TO HIS
BACK RECORD ARE- AND THEN IT.
YOU BUDGET TRAILER LIKE TO
ALLOW THE TO DO INSPECTIONS
SEVERAL WE WOULD BE A TOOL FOR
ITS TO GOING FORWARD AND I'M
HAPPY TAKE ANY QUESTIONS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU OUR BE A SEAT AT
OUR MARK HE THERE WAS A LAW OF
CONCERN LOCAL. BY MEMBERS OF.
AND THERE'S- A LOT OF ANXIETY
AS WE WAIT FOR. A CALL ROOM TO
ADDRESSING THE DEFICIENCIES IN
OVERSIGHT OF JAIL AND FOR HOW
DO YOU TO. THE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES YOUR **** FOR. I AND
ON THE COULD WE FROM. ONE OF
THE THAT WE'RE GET A LOT OF THE
SAME A LOT OF THE SAME UNTIL I.
FUNDING THAT ONE WE VOCAL
CONCERNS THE CRIME SITUATION.
THANK YOU MADAM TO AGAIN KATIE
HOW WITH THE BE A C. C. ARTICLE
WE ARE- WE WILL STRONG. IN THE
BUDGET CHAIN PROPOSED BEFORE IS.
WERE TO DIRECTION WE RECEIVE-
FROM THE GOVERNOR LAST TO
STRENGTHEN IN JAIL- OVERSIGHT-
CONTRARY TO. SOME OF WHAT'S
BEEN STATED TODAY- OUR BOARD
HAS ENGAGED- MUCH MORE DIRECTLY
WITH INFORMATION AND REGULAR
UPDATES AT EVERY SINGLE PUBLIC
BOARD MEETING- ABOUT. THE WHAT
WE'RE CALLING THE ENHANCED
INSPECTION PROCESS OR E. I. P.
AND- WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO DO
MORE WITHIN THE CURRENT
STATUTORY FRAMEWORK THAT THE B.
SEC HOUSE WHICH IS- AS THE
COMPLIANCE AGENCY. AND NOT A
REGULATORY AGENCY AND SO PART
OF WHAT I WOULD WANT TO JUST
RESPOND TO IT AT LEAST IN. ONE
IS THAT- YOU KNOW THE ALLEY. IS
MADE THAT WE PREFERRED TO DO
THINGS IN THE IN A WAY THAT'S
NOT SUFFICIENTLY RESPONSIVE TO
THE NEEDS AND CONCERNS ABOUT
PROBLEMS INSIDE THE COUNTY
JAILS. THERE WE AS WE TALKED
ABOUT IN THE MARCH- HEARING
THERE IS A GREAT DEAL OF THE-
BENEFICIAL WORK THAT'S BEING
DONE AND WILL BE DONE- UNDER
THIS PROPOSAL BY HAVING MORE
FREQUENT INSPECTIONS MORE
REGULAR REPORTING TO THE BOARD
MORE DETAILED INFORMATION GOING
OUT TO THE PUBLIC ABOUT WHAT
THE ITEMS OF NON COMPLIANCE.
ARE AND INCREASED TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE- OUR TO THE COUNTIES
SO WE THINK IT IS THAT IT IS
RESPONSIVE AND THAT ARE-
EXISTING INSPECTION PROCESS IS
BENEFICIAL- CERTAINLY NOT ONLY
TO THE COUNTIES- WHO ARE
GETTING INSPECTED FOR
COMPLIANCE WITH. REGULATIONS
BUT ALSO WITH RESPECT TO-
WHAT'S HAPPENING- AND THAT
AFFECTS THE PEOPLE WHO ARE.
RESIDING IN THE COUNTY JAILS
AND THE FAMILY MEMBERS AND
LOVED ONES WHO ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT THEM SO WE ACTUALLY
BELIEVE IT'S VERY RESPONSIVE TO
WHAT WE'VE BEEN DIRECTED TO DO-
TO STRENGTHEN THAT. THE JAIL
OVERSIGHT. I THINK I THINK AT
LEAST FOR MYSELF WE MIGHT HAVE
TO DISAGREE FOR NOW BUT BEFORE
AS THE DIGITAL QUESTIONS MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
ON THIS ITEM. OKAY US THIS
WOULD HAVE- THE TIONAL
QUESTIONS WERE RECOMMENDING
THAT WE HOLD THIS ITEM. OPEN AS
AS WE CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD-
WE HOPE TO GET SOME ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION ABOUT A PLAN OF
ACCOMPLISHMENTS- TO. SHAKE JEFF
DENIED DEFICIENCIES- NORTH
OFFICIAL SO SHE YOU'RE NOT OUT
OF JAIL. IT'S JEFF THE
NEIGHBORHOOD APARTMENT FINANCE.
ONE OF THE MORE REALLY QUICKLY
IF. IN OVERSIGHT- SHE
REPORTEDLY YES MIGHT THAT WE
SIGNIFICANTLY ABOUT THE CENTRAL
STATEMENT. PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION TO ALL STAKEHOLDERS
THE LEGISLATURE ADVOCATES-
ANYBODY WITH THANKS. LET'S
HOUSING COUNTY JAIL. HUSET THE
FOR THAT I WOULD THAT WE HAVE
THE COMMON OF TRêN AND ACCOUNT
IN THE SAID THE THAT I BEEN
ASKED AT- AND THAT COULD AND
I'M NOT CONVINCED THAT WE ARE
IN THE PATHWAY IT- TO FOR
COMPREHENSIVE. REFORMS ENSURE
THE WE HAVE OVERSIGHT AND THAT.
BUSINESS AS USUAL WITH MY GONNA
COME. WITH THAT SO WILL LOOK
FORWARD TO THAT CAN DISK A A
THE FACT OPEN. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR THANK YOU GOING TO GO
AHEAD AND ON TO A- FIX I SIX
AND FINAL AT FOR THIS- AND
THAT'S THE WE HAVE THE HELL
CARE WITH. AND FOR. WE HAVE THE
OF AND- DELEO. FRIEDMAN ROBERTS
APARTMENT IF. THE PROPOSAL THAT
YOU HAVE BEFORE YOU LISTEN YOUR
FOR THE HELP CARE FOR THE
IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM BY FORTY
THREE MILLION TWO HUNDRED
THIRTY BY THOUSAND ALL THE
PREVIOUS IN THE IN THE THREE IN-
AUTHORIZATIONS TREAT FOR
TRAILER THOUGH HAVEN'T FULLY
OUT TO THE- LET'S PROPOSED
TRAILER BILL. AGAINST REQUEST
TO MAKE MY- REPORTING TO ANY
ALLOCATE AUTHORIZED BY THE FOR
THE WORKS FOR FOOD REST THE L.
A. CONCERN ABOUT FUNDS BEING
OUT TO HELP APPLICANTS NOT
PROGRAM FOR ALCATEL FUNNY.
ABOUT THE HEALTHCARE FACILITY
IN PROGRAM AND IT'S WITH FROM
THAT FUNDS. THANK YOU THAT L.
H. TOMORROW TE L. A. O. I'M
TRYING TO THE MORE FACT ON PRO-
AND THOUSAND THROUGH SB TWENTY
TWO THE LEFT OR JUST OVER NINE
MILLION EXCEPT THESE FROM
AUTHORITY FOR ALL
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECT CITY ARE.
TYPICALLY THAT IF PROJECTS
WITHIN A X. SPEAKING TYPICALLY
MEDICAL. AND PRESENCE OF. IT
ALSO ALLOWED THEM CARE HE SAID
ARE ALL BUT PROJECT OF MY CROWD
FOR THE FOR THE BUDGETING NOT
ONLY GETS A LOT O IMAGES
ARGUMENT TOTAL. THAT WOULD HAVE
BY TWENTY WITH NOTIFICATION TO
THE CHECKPOINT BLOCKADE BUT WE
CAN. AUGMENT THIS AMOUNT BY AN
ADDITIONAL ONE HUNDRED NINETY
POINT ONE MILLION OR EIGHTEEN
POINT 5% OF THE TOTAL AMOUNT.
OF THE DEPARTMENT PROJECTED THE
TOTAL COST INCREASES BUT- I
MEAN A LOT OF TECHNICAL
PROJECTS. AND WHAT CONTENT TO
EXHAUST THE FIFTEEN POINT ONE
MILLION THAT COMMINGLED
MEETINGS BUT WITH THE 20%
AUGMENTATION LIMIT. AS A RESULT
IS REQUESTING FORTY THREE POINT
TWO MILLION ADDITIONAL THESE
REVENUE AUTHORITY THIS COULD
RESULT IN A TOTAL OF FIFTY ONE
POINT EIGHT MILLION IF THE ON-
IF IT METRIC IN AUGMENTED BY
20% IS THAT ARE NOT ALLOWED TO
DO- QUALIFY TO GENERATE FOR ME
TO INCREASE THE LEAD TRACK
RECORDING FOR THESE PROJECTS.
WE DO NOT THINK IT WOULD BE
pADDITIONAL NEEDS REVENUE
AUTHORITY FOR PROJECTS AT
PRESENT OF CLOTHES IN THE NEAR
FUTURE. DUE TO THE DECLINE FOR
THE POPULATION CITIES ARE
HOUSING AUTHORITY CUTS TO
BRITAIN'S BY TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE AND WE ESTIMATE THAT THE
STATE WILL BE IN A POSITION TO
CLOSE ANOTHER THREE PRESENCE BY
TWENTY TWENTY FORTY FIVE. HR
NAY SHOWING YOU STRONG
CANDIDATES FOR ADDITIONAL
CLOSURES IN CLEVELAND.
CALIFORNIA REHABILITATION
CENTER IN NORCO THE SENATE
WEDNESDAY PRESENTED THE
CORRECTIONAL TRAINING FACILITY
AT SOLEDAD AND CALIFORNIA BANDS
COLUMNS CALLING THE CDC AND
SAMUS OBISPO. AND IT WAS
ELECTED BASED ON THEIR HIGH
ESTIMATED COST FOR REPAIRS MY
OPERATIONAL COSTS OR BOTH
RELATIVE. TO THE INMATE
CAPACITY. AND DESPITE SEEING
BEING A STRONG CABINET
FORECLOSURE OR CITIES HOUSING
THAT POINT MILLION THE PROPOSED
FUNNY WHAT BE A LOT FOR IT THE
PRODUCT. AT CDC. WE'RE MODIFY
THAT FOR TO ENSURE THAT IT IS
AN SPENT US- PRISONS ARE WILL
BE CLOSELY BUT- AFTER THE
COMPLETION- SPECIFICALLY
RECOMMEND DIRECTING
ADMINISTRATION TO BUY TO LIST
BUT NEVER VISION- PRISONS THAT
ARE STRONG CANDIDATES FOR
CLOVER. AT THE END OF THE
LEGISLATURE COULD USE THIS
INFORMATION TO DETERMINE IF IT
AGREES WITH THAT ASSESSMENT OUR
THE CONTACT PERSONS. OTHER THAN
THE WITH PROVIDED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION. WOULD BE STRONG
AND IT'S FOR CLOSER. NEXT
MEMBER COMMENDED OFTEN BUDGET
TRAILER STUDY TO. PROHIBIT
MINISTRATION FROM USING
ADDITIONAL THESE REVENUE THIRTY
FOUR AND THE PROJECT
OPPORTUNITIES THAT THE
LEGISLATURE VIEWS I STRONG
CANDIDATES FOR CULTURAL. AND
THEN WE RECOMMEND ADJUSTING THE
INCREASING THE LEASE REVENUE
AUTHORITY ACCORDINGLY FOR
EXAMPLE IF THE LEGISLATURE
AGREES THAT SEEMS TO THE TRUCK
HEADED FOR CLOSURE OR IT COULD
REDUCE THE PROPOSAL PLEASE. BY
THE EIGHT POINT TWO MILLION
DOLLARS AT THE MINUTE TREATMENT
INDICATED WOULD GO TOWARDS OUR
PROJECT. AND FINALLY RECOMMEND
DIRECTING THE MINISTRATIONS NOT
USE ITS ABILITY TO AUGMENT THE
LEGISLATIVE THE APPROVED PLEASE
REVENUE AUTHORITY- TO PROVIDE
FUNDING FOR THE PROJECT AT
PRISONS OF THE LEGISLATURE HAS
THE TRUMP RESTAURANT. NAMES
FORECLOSURE. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT YOU I DON'T HAVE A CLUE
WHICH IS MORE OF A- BEFORE OPEN
UP TO MY CAR. WITH HAS BEEN
DISCUSSED HERE WE'VE BEEN
WAITING FOR SOME SORT OF PLAN
TO ENSURE THAT. WE ARE PLANNING
ACCORDINGLY SO WE'RE NOT
INVESTING IN PROCESS THAT WE'RE
GONNA BE. CLOSING DOWN THE
FIRST PERSON THAT WE ARE
CLOSING THIS FALL HALF OF
BUYING HEALTH CARE FACILITY
THAT. WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE
SEEN. AND SO IT'S HARD. TO BE
LOOKING AT THE SPRING UPDATES
AT FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDING AT
THE SAN WITHOUT THAT
INFORMATION. BEFORE US. DO WE
HAVE ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MISTER
LUCKY. YEAH LIKE AS YOU JUST
INDICATED WHEN WE SPOKE IN LATE
MARCH. WE'RE LED TO BELIEVE
THAT THERE WASN'T A PRIOR TO
CLOSURE LIST AVAILABLE. HOWEVER
ON APRIL THIRTEENTH THE
DEPARTMENT ANNOUNCED ADDITIONAL
PRISON CLOSURE ALONG WITH THE
CLOSURE OF. TWO MINIMUM
SECURITY GUARDS. SO WHAT WE'RE
WONDERING IS CONCEDING C. OUR
GUARANTEE THAT NONE OF THESE
REMAINING TWELVE. HEALTHCARE
FACILITY IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM
PROJECT WILL BE CONSTRUCTED A
PRESENCE LIKELY TO CLOSE WITHIN
THE NEXT FIVE YEARS. JUST NEED
A MINUTE BY MINUTE FINANCING
KEEP ASKING THIS BUT I DO WANT
TO NOTE THERE IS CONSIDERABLE
UNCERTAINTY WITH THE FUTURE.
PRESIDENT OF YOUR PLANS WE ARE
MAKING CONSIDERABLE EFFORTS TO
REDUCE OPERATIONAL. AND CLOSE
PRESENTS- AS YOU MENTIONED
RECENTLY ANNOUNCED THE CLOSURE
OF THE CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL
CENTER SUSANVILLE- HOWEVER WE
DO KNOW THAT THERE IS
CONSIDERABLE UNCERTAINTY ABOUT
THE FUTURE POPULATION TRENDS-
THERE ARE OTHER FACTORS AS WELL
INCLUDING COMPANY NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. EMPHASIZING THE NEED
FOR INCREASED BASED SO WE
AREN'T SURE NECESSARILY WHAT
CAPACITY MIGHT LOOK LIKE IN THE
FUTURE GIVEN THOSE- AND
INTERROGATION ISSUES WE ALSO
WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT- THERE
IS A SIGNIFICANT BACKLOG BOTH
IN THE COUNTY JAILS AND IN THE
STATE COURT SYSTEMS. WILL
LIKELY RESULT IN SOME INCREASE
IN PRISON POPULATION IN THE
NEAR FUTURE AND THERE ARE
SEVERAL- CONCERNS AND PROBLEMS
WITH IDENTIFYING BREAKING FOR
FUTURE CLOSURE OR EVEN
INCLUDING ON A LIST- THOSE
MEDICAL ISSUES WITH STAFFING.
WE ANNOUNCE ESTRELAS THAT THE
ALEJO'S RECOMMENDED A CERTAIN
NUMBER PRISON BETTER LIKELY
CANDIDATES FOR CLOSURE WE
ANTICIPATE THAT THERE COULD BE
STAFFING CONCERNS YOU CAN ALSO.
CAUSE ISSUES WITH IMPROVING
THOSE FACILITIES IN THE
MEANTIME WHILE WE WAIT FOR THAT
REASON CLOSER TO BE DETERMINED
IF THOSE INSTITUTIONS IF THE
LEGISLATURE HOLDS OFF ON
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR THINGS
LIKE FACILITIES OUR
PROGRAMMING. I MAKE A
COMPROMISE IN A- STAFF SAFETY
ORDER ON REHABILITATIVE PROGRAM
AT THAT FACILITIES. AND SO
AGAIN WE ARE REALLY. SINCE AS
WELL WE MAKING FUTURE INVEST IN
PRISON THAT ARE. FOR CLOSE BUT
WE CAN WANT IT IT'S BEING THE-
I. AND REPEAT SOME ISSUES THAT
WE HAD IN THE PAST. A PREVIOUS
THANK TWELVE ZERO WAS FOR
CLOSURE. IT DIDN'T END UP
HAPPENING AND THERE WERE SOME
SIGNIFICANT. LOSSES THERE FOR
HEALTHCARE FACILITIES- IT
DIDN'T OCCUR BECAUSE THE
ANTICIPATION. FOR CLOSURE BUT
IT DIDN'T HAPPEN SO CAN WE
UNDERSTAND THE CONCERN BUT IT'S
VERY DIFFICULT AND I'M SORRY TO
PROVIDE LISTS OF. POTENTIAL
PRISON CLOSURES WITHOUT KIND OF
FULLY ASSESSING. THE CURRENT
SITUATION WHAT THINGS WILL LOOK
LIKE. MANAGER YES THE JUNGLE IF
I MAY THIS IS CAITLYN L'ITALIEN
JUST TO QUICKLY OFFER- SOME AN
ALTERNATIVE PERSPECTIVE ON
THOSE POINTS- THAT MINISTRATION
IS PROJECTING A DECLINE IN THE
INMATE POPULATION- THAT IT'S
AND CONSISTENT WITH OUR
ESTIMATES IS EXACTLY WHAT WE
GET OUR ESTIMATE THAT- THE
STATE COULD BE IN A POSITION TO
CLOSE- 5% OVER THE NEXT FEW
YEARS- WELL THERE THERE IS OF
COURSE AND CERTAINLY THERE'S
ALWAYS UNCERTAINTY- AROUND
POPULATION PROJECTIONS AND WE
WOULDN'T WE CERTAINLY WOULDN'T
RECOMMEND MOVING FORWARD OUT OF
PRISON CLOSURE IF IT WOULD
COMPROMISE PUBLIC HEALTH OR-
YOU KNOW. EXACERBATE A LAWSUIT
SITUATION- HOWEVER WE DO THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO BE AWARE OF-
WHAT PRISONS ARE LIMITATION IS
CONSIDERING FOR CLOSURE SO THAT
IT CAN MAKE INFORMED DECISIONS
ABOUT CAPITAL OUTLAY AS THESE
PROJECTS ARE VERY EXPENSIVE
AND- THERE IS A VERY
SIGNIFICANT NEED FOR CAPITAL
OUTLAY IMPROVEMENTS ACROSS THE
SYSTEM SO- WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT THAT CAPITAL
INVESTMENTS ARE MADE- WHERE
THEY'RE MOST NEEDED MORE THERE
AND HAVE THEM BUT THE BIGGEST
LONG TERM BENEFITS FOR THE
STATE'S OKAY YES THERE'S
UNCERTAINTY ON THE POPULATION
BUT WE STILL HAVEN'T WE'RE.
MAKING DECISIONS NONETHELESS SO.
THE HAVING FROM ON. AND THEN ON
THE SECOND POINT ABOUT-
STAFFING ISSUES. WE DON'T
NECESSARILY SEE THAT AS A
PROHIBITIVE ISSUE OF COURSE
THERE'S ALWAYS GOING TO BE
TRADE OFFS WITH ANY KIND OF
OPERATIONAL DECISION AND
PRESENT ANNOUNCEMENT- BUT THERE
MAY BE ALTERNATIVE. SOLUTIONS
TO CONSIDER SUCH AS OFFERING-
BONUSES FOR STAFF TO AND I
STAYED AT THE PRESENT UNTIL IT
IS CLOSED- RATHER THAN MOVING
ON- I ALSO KNOW THAT WHEN WE
VISITED ACT C. R. C. IN THE
MORNING HAD ACTUALLY INDICATED
THAT SHE WAS USING. PRISON
BEATS ARE EXPECT ARE PRESENT
CLOSER TO THAT HAS BEEN A ON
THAT PRISON OVER THE PAST.
COUPLE DECADES AS A WAY TO
MOTIVATE STAFF TO DO BETTER AND
BETTER SO- AND IT'S CETAINLY-
HAD BEEN AWARE THAT THE PRISON
WAS HAD BEEN PUT ON THE
CHOPPING BLOCK IN THE PAST BUT
IT WHAT. IT SEEMED TO BE
SOMETHING THAT ONLY KIND
MOTIVATED THEM SO I JUST WANTED
TO PUT OUT POINT OUT THOSE AT
IS WELL AS THE FACT THAT STAFF
MIGHT REALLY APPRECIATE KNOWING
THAT- THAT THEY MAY ONLY BE UP
THIS PERSON FOR NUMBER. ANOTHER
TWO OR THREE YEARS AND CAN PLAN
THEIR LIFE- ACCORDINGLY SO JUST
WANTED. TO ADD THAT THOSE KIND
OF POINTS THANK YOU. LIKE I TO
MAKE SURE YOUR COME. AND THAT
SORT OF YOU- DID HAVE A FOLLOW
UP BASED ON THE ANSWER FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE BUT I
WANTED TO MAKE SURE. I DON'T
THINK I'M GONNA GET A BETTER. I
GUESS I SHOULD AS A METHOD OF
STUDY BUT- HE HAD AN ANSWER. I
THINK THE COMMITTEE HAS BEEN
CLEAR IN THE LAST YEAR INTO
THAT THE SENSORS THAT HAVE BEEN
SATISFACTORY OF THE FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND I
COULD GO BACK TO SOME OF THE
ANSWERS HE GAVE HIM TO MISTER
LUCKY'S QUESTIONS HE TALKED
ABOUT THERE BEING A SIGNIFICANT
BACKLOG- CAN YOU EXPLAIN OR-
EXPAND ON THAT. THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION- AS A RESULT THE
CURRENT AFFAIRS AND I THINK WE
IT THE ADMINISTRATION ANNOUNCED
THAT A TEMPORARY STOPPAGE THE
INTAKE TWO PRESENTS FROM COUNTY
JAIL START BELIEVE THERE'S A
BACKLOG OF APPROXIMATELY TEN
THOUSAND INMATES. WE'VE BEEN
COMMITTED TO SEE IF THERE ARE.
STILL AWAITING. A COUNTY JAIL
TRANSFER THE RECENTLY REOPENED
THAT TRANSFER- THE PAST SEVERAL
WEEKS SO IT'S RAMPING UP BUT
THERE IS STILL A SIGNIFICANT
BACKLOG THAT. WE ARE ALSO
UNSURE OF THE IMPACT OF THE
CURRENT AFFAIRS ENDEMIC ON
COUNTY COURT COMMITMENTS. AND
THEIR ACTUAL ACTIONS AS FAR AS
HAVING THOSE HEARINGS AND
SENTENCING INDIVIDUALS TO
PRISONS IN JAIL. SO WE AREN'T
YET SURE OF WHAT THE INCREASE.
ON THE COURT. WORK BUT MIGHT
RESULT. IN AS FAR AS HE
DISCOVERS POPULATION. THIS IS A
MATH EATING THERE'S ABOUT AT
THAT. CASES THEM BACK WILL BUT-
ACCORDING TO THE REPORT THAT
THE L. A. O. REFERENCE THEIR
SHIFTING SEVENTY TWO THOUSAND.
NOTIFY A THOUSAND CURRENTLY OR
SELL IN COUNTY JAILS AND AN
UNKNOWN AMOUNT POTENTIALLY IN
THE COURTS. ARM OKAY SO WHEN
YOU HAVE MORE INFORMATION ON.
ON SOME OF THOSE I KNOW WE
WOULD APPRECIATE YOU SHARING
THAT WITH US. AS WELL AND THEN
YOU ALSO REFERENCE- THAN
CERTAINTY WITH. OVER IN THE
PANDEMIC THE WORLD IN DEALING
WITH AND WE ARE. EVERY DAVIS
WITH THE ANSWERED ANY- AND ARE
LESS OUT THERE BUT WE HAVE SEEN
AN INCREASE IN. THE NATION
ACROSS THE STATE INCLUDING- AT
WITH CDC ARE. I THINK THERE'S
AN 80% ACCEPTANCE RATE FROM.
INMATES THERE AS WELL AND WE'VE
SEEN A STEEP DECLINE IN
AFFECTION FULFILL PHYSICIANS-
THERE AS WELL. AND SO IS IT
FAIR TO CONTINUE SO THAT THERE
IS THIS LARGE UNKNOWN DUE TO
THE PANDEMIC. THIS PARTICULAR
PANDEMIC YES BUT IT AGAIN IS.
OBVIOUSLY CAME OUT OF NOWHERE
LAST YEAR AND SO WE AREN'T
NECESSARILY SURE FUTURE
PANDEMICS OR ANY. FUTURE
POTENTIAL PATHOGENS AND I DO
HAVE A ACTUALLY ON THAT COURT
AGUIAR-CURRY MADAM CHAIR OF THE
COURT RIGHT NOW HAS A BACKLOG
OF ABOUT. SIXTY FIVE THOUSAND
TO NINETY THOUSAND FELONY CASE.
SIXTY FIVE THOUSAND TO NINETY
THOUSAND BACKLOGGED CASES. YES
IN ABOUT 12% OF THOSE ARE
COMING TO CREEK GENERALLY BASED
ON HISTORICAL TRENDS. SO OR
FOLLOW UP WITH A TO MAKE SURE
THOSE ARE US ACTUALLY CDCR
CASES AN ARTIST ALL CASES AND
IN GENERAL THE NUMBER THINGS A
LITTLE LATER- THE WITH. MY
COLLEAGUES IT'S. ARM THIRTY
AGAIN JUST WANT TO EMPHASIZE
THAT WE ARE WAITING FOR A
LITTLE MORE PLANNING ON THAT
CAPITAL OUTLAY AND SO YES WE
CAN LEARN FROM PREVIOUS MOMENTS
BUT THAT SHOULDN'T DETER US
FROM DOING OUR JOB ENSURING
THAT WE ARE MANAGING OUR TAX
DOLLARS RESPONSIBLY AND SO
TODAY WE WILL BE HOLDING THIS
ITEM. OPEN BEFORE I GO ON TO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IF I WANT
TO PUBLIC COMMENT ON THESE
ITEMS. I DO HAVE ALL THE
MEMBERS PRESENT SO MANY TAKE A
PAUSE AND I'M GOING TO RETURN
TO OUR VOTE ONLY ITEMS. AND SO
IN ORDERTO HELP US WITH THAT
BECAUSE THEY WERE GOING TO BE
GROUP IN SOME OF THESE ITEMS.
TOGETHER WE HAVE CONSULTED WITH
OUR REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES ON
THESE GROUPING. THE FIRST VOTE
WILL BE ABLE ONLY FOR ISSUE.
ITEMS. ONE THREE EIGHT TEN
TWELVE M. FIFTEEN- AS BUDGETED.
REPEAT THAT FAMOUS SOMETHING IN
THERE SO I APOLOGIZE ONE. THREE
EIGHT TEN ELEVEN TWELVE AND
FIFTEEN BEST BUDGET WE HAVE A
MOTION. WE HAVE A MOTION BY MR
STONE IN A SECOND BY MISTAKE BY
A THAT IS CAN STATUS CALL THE
ROLL GARCIA I. JONES SAWYER HI
BLACKIE MARK STONE RIGHT NOW
THERE. THANK YOU THAT HAS BEEN
APPROVED. NEXT WE'RE GOING TO
VOTE TO REJECT ISSUE ITEMS TWO
AND THIRTEEN WE HAVE A MOTION
SECOND SO MOVED BY MR STONE AND
SECOND BY MR JONES SAWYER.
STAFF PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
GARCIA I DON'T FOR BY NINETY
FIVE DOWN RIGHT HI THERE HI.
HAS BEEN ADOPTED THANK YOU. CAN
WE WILL NOW BE DOING INDIVIDUAL
VOTES ON THE REMAINING ITEMS.
FOR VOTE ONLY ISSUE FOR THE
VOTERS TO ADOPT A PLACEHOLDER
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO
CONSOLIDATE THE STATE COURT
FACILITIES CONSTRUCTION FUND
AND DEVIATING CRITICAL NEED TO
COUNT. WE HAVE A MOTION SHIRKAN
SOME OF MY MISTER STONE SECOND
AYE MR JONES SAWYER STAFF
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL GARCIA I
JONES SAWYER HI MACKEY. WITH
THIS ISSUE NUMBER FOUR. FIVE
STONE RIGHT BALLADEER HI. THAT
MEASURE HAS BEEN APPROVED. FOR
VOTE ONLY ISSUE NUMBER FIVE THE
VOTERS TO APPROVE S. BUDGETED
THE VARIOUS PROPOSALS
IMPLEMENTED DEFLATION RELATED
TO FIREARMS WE HAVE A MOTION
SECOND MOVE BY MR STONE SECOND
MY MISTER JONES SAWYER STAFF
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. GARCIA I
DON'T SWEAR BY MARQUEE LOW.
STONE GALLAGHER NO THAT ITEM
HAS BEEN APPROVED. FOR VOTE
ONLY ISSUE NUMBER SIX THE
VOTERS TO APPROVE THE TASK
FORCE TO STUDY AND DEVELOP
REPARATION PROPOSALS FOR
AFRICAN AMERICANS AND AFRICAN
AMERICANS WE HAVE A MOTION.
SECOND OVER MISTER STONE SECOND
MY MISTER JONES SAWYER STAFF
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL GARCIA I.
HI. DOWN THERE. THAT ITEM HAS
BEEN APPROVED. FOR VOTE ONLY
ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN THE VOTERS
TO APPROVE THE BUDGET PROPOSAL
RELATED TO FIREARM AND
INSPECTIONS WE HAVE A MOTION
CHECK IN MOVE BY MR STONE
SECOND BY MR JONES SAWYER STAFF
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL GARCIA HI
JONES SAWYER HI. BLACK OKAY.
TELL. THANK YOU THAT ITEM HAS
BEEN APPROVED. HARPER VOTE ONLY
ISSUE NUMBER NINE THE VOTERS
THAT THE PLACEHOLDER TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE TO ADJUST THE
DATE FOR THE CURIOUS PROPOSAL
WE HAVE A MOTION SECOND. MORE
FOR MR STONE SECOND MY MISTER
JONES SAWYER FAT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL GARCIA I. JONES SAWYER
HI LACKEY ARE. STONE RIGHT NOW
THEY'RE NOT WORKING. THANK YOU
THAT ITEM HAS BEEN APPROVED AND
THEN OUR FINAL ITEM FOR VOTE
ONLY ISSUE NUMBER FOURTEEN. THE
LOTUS ADOPT ELLIE A
RECOMMENDATION RELATED TO THE
QUALITY MANAGEMENT AND PATIENT
SAFETY PROPOSAL. MOVER MISTER
STONE SECOND BY MR JONES SAWYER.
STAFF PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
GARCIA HI JONES SAWYER HI.
LACKEY. I FOUND THAT ARE THERE.
THAT ITEM IS OUT BEEN APPROVED
THANK YOU. BUT THERE NEED A
VOUCHER. BUT CHANGE. FIVE SIX.
PROMOTE ONLY ISSUE NUMBER SIX
NOTRE YES. MISTER LACKING NOTED
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
THAT CONCLUDES OUR VOTE ONLY I
DON'T FOR TODAY WE'RE GONNA GO
AHEAD AND WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
ON TO PUBLIC COMMENT. WE ARE
ACCEPTING PUBLIC COMMENT BOTH
IN THE HEARING ROOM AND ON THE
PHONE THE PHONE NUMBER TO
CONNECT THIS IN THE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. THE AGENDA IT'S ALSO
ON THE AGENDA. AND SHOULD ALSO
BE ON THE SCREEN OF YOUR
STREAMING THE HEARING. JUST IN
CASE. THE NUMBER IS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN ACCESS CODE. ONE
THREE ONE FIVE FOUR THREE
SEVEN. IF YOU ENCOUNTER ANY
PROBLEMS PLEASE CONTACT THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE AT.
916-319-2099 AND STAFF WILL
ASSIST YOU WE ALSO ENCOURAGE
THE PUBLIC TO PROVIDE WRITTEN
PUBLIC TESTIMONY AS WELL WHICH
CAN BE SUBMITTED TO BUDGETS OF
FIVE AT A. S. M. DOT C. A. THE
ABOVE AND IS ALSO LISTED ON THE
AGENDA. DO WE HAVE ANYONE IN
THE ROOM WISHING TO SPEAK.
FIFTEEN NON. OPERATOR PLEASE
OPEN THE BOWLING FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT EACH PERSON HAS A TWO
ONE MINUTE FOR THE PUBLIC
COMMENTS. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT ON TODAY'S CALL
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. OUR FIRST MY
NUMBER IS. LINE TWENTY TWO.
LINE TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON EDDIE FISHER CAR WITH
CHILDREN'S DEFENSE FUND
CALIFORNIA AND I'M COMMENTING
ON ITEM FIVE TWO TWO SEVEN
ISSUE FIVE. THE ONLY KEEP UP TO
BE A FIFTY BUDGET PROPOSAL WE
URGE YOU TO ADOPT IS GRANTING
THE PSPP AUTHORITY TO CONDUCT
UNANNOUNCED INSPECTIONS WHICH
CAN BE DONE WITHOUT ADDITIONAL
FUNDING. HOWEVER WE URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO REJECT THE
REMAINDER OF THE BUDGET
PROPOSAL. WELL IT'S PRETTY.
BIRTH THE CURRENT INSPECTION
PROCESS IS DEEPLY FLAWED A
FINDING SUPPORTED BY THE LA IT
WAS RECENT REPORT WHICH
HIGHLIGHTED CONCERNS ABOUT THE
QUALITY OF INSPECTIONS. CARRIED
OUT BY THE BSP SPEAK UNTIL THE
PSPP IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF
INSPECTION INCREASING THE
NUMBER OF INSPECTIONS DOES
NOTHING. SECOND THE TITLE
REGULATIONS THAT UNDERLIE THE
BSP FEES INSPECTION FALL SHORT
AND MUST BE REVISED PRIOR TO
FUNDING MORE INSPECTION FOR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. IT MAKES
NO SENSE THE FUND INCREASED
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE FOR
REGULATIONS THAT HAVE
REPEATEDLY FAILED TO CONDUCT
ATTACKS ADULT AND YOU CAN FIND
IN OUR COUNTY. THE BSE FEEDING
THE CORRECT ADDRESS UPDATING
STRENGTHENING THESE REGULATION
UNTIL THE UNDERLYING
DEFICIENCIES SURROUNDING
INSPECTIONS AND REGULATIONS ARE
ADDRESS. ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
THE B. S. B. C. IT PREMATURE
AND BASEBALL AND WE URGE YOU TO
REJECT ANY BUDGET INCREASES FOR
THE BSEB. AT THE TIME THANK YOU.
ONE FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT I THINK
NEW MADAM CHAIR MY NAME IS
MIGUEL GARCIA WITH ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION I WANT IT
GONE ISSUE NUMBER FIVE. I WOULD
WE RECOMMEND THAT THE DEITY
EXPAND THE COMPOSITION OF THE
AGENCY THIRTEEN PERSON BOARD TO
INCLUDE SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS
AND THOSE MOST IMPACTED BY THE
BOY'S DECISION MAKING IF YOU
CAN COULD YOU REPRESENTATION
THE BALL ABOUT THE AGENCIES. IN
CHARGE OF TITLE FIFTEEN AND
TWENTY FOUR FACILITY REGULATION.
WE ALSO RECOMMEND THAT.
ANNOUNCED IT SHOULD BE
PRIORITIZED AND DOES NOT
REQUIRE ANY ADDITIONAL FUNDING
THANK YOU TAKE MY REQUEST INTO
CONSIDERATION. NINE TWENTY.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS A TOUGH A LOT OF THE POLICY
PROGRAM DIRECTOR AT LEAST TALK
BECAUSE OF MONTEREY AND SANTA
CRUZ COUNTY M. WE HAVE
WITNESSED THE BCC'S COLOR TO
PROTECT PEOPLE AND LOCAL
FACILITY WITH. ONGOING PROBLEMS
OF THE BTC THERE ARE CAUSED BY
STRUCTURAL THE PROJECT
INCLUDING I'M CLEAR OVERSIGHT
PROGRAM M. PROGRAMMATIC
LEADERSHIP WE ARE REQUESTING
THAT YOU REJECT THIS PROPOSAL
WE- WE ARE NOT. THEY ARE NOT
PARTICIPATING IN DEFENSIVELY M.
ATTENTION SHOULD BE PART OF THE
CORE BUNCH THANK YOU. NINE
TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO I'M
THINKING ON ITEM FIVE MY NAME
IS BABYLON EDWARDS AND I WORK
WITH INDIVIDUALS WITH RESPECT
COUNTY TAB CITY IN THE PAST
YEAR PEOPLE RIVERSIDE JOB
EXPERIENCE TORTURED CONDITION
FROM BEING CONFINED TO THEIR
CELLS FOR TWENTY THREE HOURS
PER DAY TO BEING DENIED
LIFESAVING MEDICATION. MENTAL
HEALTH CARE AND CLEANING
SUPPLIE DESPITE REGULARLY
REPORTING CONDITION FANTASY
JUNO WILL BE COMMITTEE EIGHTY
THREE THIS IS BECAUSE THE
AGENCY CULTURE AND BOARD
MEMBERSHIP FAILED TO BACK TO
THE WELL BEING OF INCARCERATED
PEOPLE IN BOTH THE MINIMUM
STANDARDS REGULATIONS AND AN
EXTRACTION PROCESS. THE
HORRIFYING AFTER MENTION
CONDITION TECHNICALLY NEED TO
BE A COMPLETE MINIMUM STANDARDS
OF CARE FURTHER THE BCC
PRIMARILY RELIES ON INFORMATION
PROVIDED BY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT RATHER THAN A CAR
THIRTY PEOPLE TO IT THAT JOE
COMMISSION. IT WOULD HAVE TO BE
A FIFTY NOTHING TO REVIEW AND
STRENGTHEN THEIR NON STANDARD
WITH COMMUNITY INPUT IT COSTS
THE INSPECTION TEAM NOTHING TO
CREATE A FORMAL PROCESS TO
GATHER INFORMATION FROM
INCARCERATED PEOPLE ABOUT THEIR
LIVING CONDITIONS. UNTILTHE
AGENCY MAKES THE CHANGES IN
DEMONSTRATE YOUR COMMITMENT TO
THE WELL BEING OF THE PEOPLE
THEY ARE MEANT TO PROTECT- WE
OPPOSE INCREASING THEIR BUDGET.
THANK YOU. ONE NINETEEN. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN GO. HELLO YOU MY
NAME IS SAMANTHA KRAMER I'M
CALLING TODAY AN AFFILIATION
WITH- THE CORPORATE SACRAMENTO
NO FOR THE ANTHROPOLOGY
DEPARTMENT AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA DAVIS. WELL I'M
CALLING TODAY BECAUSE I THANK
TO SUPPORT THE V. THIRTY S.
SACRAMENTO THE COUNTY THE
LEGISLATURE OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA DE NINE BUDGET
ALLOCATIONS TO SUPPORT FORM
SHUT DOWN THE PRESIDENT LIKE
PRESIDENTS LIKE BUT CDC ARE
PROPOSING FOR DVI AND BCC WHICH
WILL ONLY LEAD FURTHER
OPPORTUNITIES IN THE FUTURE USE
TOXIC FACILITIES AND ENDANGER
MORE LIVES. WE MUST ADOPT
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THAT
REQUIRES CDC ARJUN NAME
PERMANENT CLOSURE DATE FOR
THESE TWO FACILITIES AND MANY
MORE FACILITIES TO BE
PERMANENTLY CLOSED IN THE NEAR
FUTURE THAT MEANS PERHAPS FIVE
FACILITIES NOT ONLY TO
FACILITIES PERMANENT PRISON
PRISON CLOSURE IS NECESSARY IT
IS A PUBLIC HEALTH CATASTROPHE
ALSO THE STATE MUST INVEST IN
COMMUNITY RESOURCE OF THE
CENTRE CARE AND DIVERT PEOPLE
FROM CRISIS THAT MEANS WE HAVE
COMMUNITY HEALTH INTERVENTIONS.
BEFORE THAT DOWNWARD SPIRAL
THAT REQUIRES LAW ENFORCEMENT
INTERVENTION AND INCARCERATION
BUILDING WITH AND INVESTING IN
COMMUNITIES NOT JUST SHUTTING
DOWN PRESIDENT THAT ACTUALLY
THE. REAL ANSWER TO PUBLIC
SAFETY. THESE ON THE- OF THE
INTEREST IN HEALTH. THE ROUTE
SHARES. ALL FUNDS FROM BUILDING
NEW PRISONS EXPANDING PRESENCE
WE WANT TO REDUCE PRISON
POPULATIONS AND REDUCE CONTACT
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME TODAY. NINE
EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME'S
MONIQUE DARLING I'M A MEMBER OF
THE SURGE IN THE BAY AREA
THAT'S SHOWING UP FOR RACIAL
JUSTICE I'M- CALLING ABOUT
ISSUE SIX HEALTHCARE FACILITY
IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM- THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS HAS
ADDRESSES IN THEIR COMMENTARY.
BUT I DO NOT BELIEVE THAT THREE
D. VR HAS A PLAN FOR PICKING
COAST CLOSURE. A COALITION
CALLED THE COALITION A
CALIFORNIANS FOR RESPONSIBLE
BUDGET- GROUP WHICH IS A
COALITION OF MORE THAN EIGHTY
ORGANIZATIONS WHO ARE EXPERT
DANTE CARDS ARRANGEMENT PUBLIC
POLICY. HAS BEEN GATHERING DATA
FROM INSIDE AND OUTSIDE OF
CALIFORNIA PRISONS. WERE OVER
YEAR ON THIS ISSUE. THIS IS A
CRUCIAL DATA IN CURBS PEOPLE'S
PLAN PRESCRIPTION CLOSURE
REPORT. OFFERING GOVERNMENT
ACTORS IN INITIAL ROADMAP FOR
SHUTTING DOWN STATE- PRESENCE
STARTING WITH TEN PRESENTS BY
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. ON BEHALF
OF CURB I ENCOURAGE EVERY
MEMBER ON THIS COMMITTEE TO
CLOSELY READING CONSIDER THIS
REPORT. AND TO DIRECT THE CDC
ARTICLES AT LEAST TEN PRESENT
IN THE NEXT FIVE YEARS. THANK
YOU. ONE TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS OKAY CAL ON IN AND THE
NUMBER OF INITIATE JEFF THEY
SPEND CURRENTLY IN THE
INSTITUTE FOR IMPACTED LEADERS
AND A PART OF FIELD FAMILIES
UNITED AGAIN. AND LIFE WITHOUT
PAROLE- IN I'M HERE AND BECAUSE
THE GOVERNOR PROPOSED BUDGET
ALLOCATES FUNDING FOR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH IN CAPITAL
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS. IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS PROVIDE GUIDANCE
ON HOW EXISTING FUNDING IN THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET CAN
BE ALLOCATED AND MAXIMIZE TO
SUPPORT THE NEEDS OF THE
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES.
INCREASE THE STATE'S RETURN ON
INVESTMENT AND N. IN ITS
RELIANCE ON INCARCERATION YOU
JUST AREN'T THE ANSWER WHEN I
WAS NINE MONTHS OLD MY MOTHER
WAS BRUTALLY MURDERED IN TWENTY
TWO YEARS LATER THEY ARRESTED
MY FATHER. AND I FIRSTHAND I'VE
EXPERIENCED IT THROUGH HIS
EXPERIENCE- HOW I'M JUST BEING
INSIDE IS AND HOW HOW MUCH
TRAUMA IT CREATED FOR HIM-
BEING CAGED. IN KATY MENTIONED
THAT. WOULD ACTUALLY SUPPORT-
PEOPLE THAT ARE IN CUSTODY AND
THEIR FAMILIES I COMPLETELY
DISAGREE I THINK WHAT WILL
SUPPORT PEOPLE INSIDE- IT'S
ACTUAL SUPPORT REHABILITATION-
PROGRAMMING- WHICH WERE ALSO
ADDED ADVOCATING FOR- SO WITH
THAT I. I DEFINITELY. DECLINE
ISSUE FIVE. YOU NINE THIRTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS CHRISTY
I'M WITH- CURBS AND WE AGREE
WITH THE L. A. L. THAT THE
CALIFORNIA PRISON SYSTEM THAT
WAS ESTABLISHED MANY DECADES
AGO MAY NO LONGER BE IN LINE
WITH THE STATE VIEW ON PENAL
SYSTEMS AND PUBLIC SAFETY. WE
AGREE WITH THE L. A. L. THAT
THE COMMITTEE SHOULD ADOPT
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE BECAUSE
FIVE PRESENTS NOT TO OVER THE
NEXT SEVERAL YEARS AND TO
PROHIBIT INFRASTRUCTURE
SPENDING ON PRISONS THAT ARE
SCHEDULED FOR CLOSURE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CAN POINT OUT IN
FEBRUARY HEARING YOU DON'T NEED
TO PUT A NEW ROOF. ON THE
FACILITY. THAT YOU'RE GOING TO
CLOSE IN FIVE YEARS- I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO SAY THAT I'M A
CRIME SURVIVOR AND I DON'T
BELIEVE THAT HE NEEDED SYSTEM
OF A PROVIDE ANY JUSTICE.
RONNIE ONE. THANK YOU. NINE
THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME'S ARIANNA
WITH THIRD SHOWING UP FOR
RACIAL JUSTICE AREA I'M JUST
CALLING IN TO SAY THAT THE
STATE ON LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE FURNITURE REPORT IN
NOVEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY THAT
THE DEATH OF CALIFORNIANS WITH
THIS IMPOSED 5% BY TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE BUT THEY'VE AT
LEAST ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY. AND WE AGREE
WITH THE L. A. R. THAT THE
STATE CAN AND MUST PRIORITIZE
THE CLOSURE OF MORE THAN 2% IN
THE COMING YEAR WE BELIEVE THAT
THEY SHOULD FOCUS ON CLOSING
CAN PRESENT THE NEXT FIVE YEARS
AND REINVEST THOSE FUNDS SPENT
ON REAL. FINE CLOTHING CAN
PRESENT INVESTING THE FUNDS
ALLOCATED IN REAL COMMUNITY
SOLUTION THE PEOPLE PLAN FOR
PRESIDENT CLOSER WITH THE
CREATED BY CURVE IN THE ROAD
MAP JUST FOR THAT WITHOUT THE
INVOLVEMENT OF CURRENTLY
INCARCERATED PEOPLE AND
FORMERLY INCARCERATED PEOPLE AS
WELL AS THEIR FAMILIES ACROSS
THE STATE A LOT OF PEOPLE
LIVING IN PRISON TIME AND
DISCIPLINE WILL CONTINUE TO
PRIORITIZE PROFIT OVER PEOPLE.
AND DECISIONS AROUND FOR THEM
BECAUSE THEY WILL BE GIVEN BY
THE SELF SERVING INTERESTS OF A
DEPARTMENT THAT HAS A VESTED
INTEREST IN EXPANDING RATHER
THAN CLOSING I LOVE KEEPING
PEOPLE INCARCERATED AND
PRESIDENT. YOUR CURRENT PRISON
CLOSER CLOSER DISCUSSION IS
MISSING THE VOICE OF THE PEOPLE
WITH THE MOST AT STAKE AND WHO
ARE BEST POSITIONED. TO LEAD
THESE DECISIONS. THANK YOU. MY
FIVE. YOUR MIND OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MEMBERS BUT MY
NAME IS LIZ CAN HAPPEN THEN I'M
A MEMBER OF SHOWING UP FOR
RACIAL JUSTICE THIRDS BAY AREA
AND ADVOCACY PROGRAM DIRECTOR
WITH THE WHITE OF THE STATE
BERKELEY OAKLAND I HAVE A LOVED
ONE IN FIVE DIFFERENT CORPORATE
OR FOR FORTY SIX YEARS ALSO BE
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF CURB
PEOPLE PLANT FOR PERSONAL
CLOSURE REPORT. WE ENCOURAGE
EVERY MEMBER ON THE COMMITTEE
TO CLOSELY READ AND CONSIDER
THE SUPPORT AND TO DIRECT TV C.
R. TO CLOSE AT LEAST TEN
PRESENT IN THE NEXT FIVE YEARS
ONE OF THE MANY POWERFUL
COMPONENTS INCLUDED IN THE
REPORT OUR PLAN FOR HOW
CALIFORNIA NEED DEEP INVESTMENT
COMMUNITIES. AND IN TOWNS NEAR
PREVENT THAT IN ORDER TO
REALIZE THE PROMISE OF A
CLOSURE STATEWIDE THERE MUST BE
EXPENSIVE LABOR TRANSITION
PLANS THAT NOT ONLY INCLUDE
PEOPLE CURRENTLY EMPLOYED
WITHIN CDCR BUT THAT ALSO
CREATE JOBS FOR PEOPLE BEING
BULLIED. AND PEOPLE LIVING IN
PERSON TOWN WE NEED CAREER THAT
HE'LL NOT COMMUNITIES AND TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF INDIVIDUALS
RELY ON INCOME GENERATED FROM
COMMERCIAL SYSTEMS IN THE STATE
WHICH MUST AND THIS LAND IS NOT
HEALTHY AND UNDERSTANDING TO
HELP THE EMPLOYMENT OF
LIFESAVING EFFORTS TO
TRANSITION PEOPLE INTO JOBS
THAT BENEFIT EVERYONE IN THE
COMMUNITY AND THAT DON'T HARM
THOSE WHO ARE THE MOST
MARGINALIZED SHOULD BE FUNDED
AND CENTRAL TO ANY PRISON.
CLOSURE PLAN THANK YOU. MINE
TOO ONE. YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO CAN YOU
HEAR. YEAH GO AHEAD. THANK YOU-
MONEY TO DOUBLE IMAGES- WITH
STARTING OVER AND CLEAR NUMBER
OF CURBING- AND REGARDLESS IF
YOU ARE ABOUT THE BORN ISSUE OF
TOXIC WATER DAILY STATE PRISON
IN CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL AND
FACILITY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS ACROSS CALIFORNIA
STATE PRISONS ARE CONSTANTLY
CHANGING THE TOPIC WATER IS
ABOUT REJECT WATER
CONTAMINATION AND OTHER TYPES
OF UNSAFE HEALTH CONDITION
FOUND IN OUR PRISONS LIKE
EXPOSURE TO VALLEY FEVER
EXPECTED FIVE MORE THAN MORE
SHOULD BE PRIORITIZED MAKING
DECISIONS ABOUT WHICH PRESENTS
BECAUSE- WE CARE VERY. MUCH
ABOUT PEOPLE LIVING IN UNSAFE
PRISON. IF YOU ARE MUST IN THE
HEALTH IN APPROVED. INCLUDING
THE TALK AIR LAND IN WATER
AFTER YEAH CLOTHES. BELIEVES
THE ONLY RESPONSE AND THE
PROTECT THE PUBLIC FACE AT
GRANT NOT RELEASED IT AND CLOSE
MARKET DOWN. THE LEGISLATURE
SHOULD REMOVE SHE MOVED TO
UPDATE PENAL CODE SECTION TWO
OH SIX SEVEN B. CONCLUDE THE
TOXICITY OF LAND AND WATER AND
THE CRITERIA TO CONSIDER
CRITICAL. TO MOVING FORWARD
THANK YOU. NINE THIRTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS ALEA
VIEW BY MOST SEARCH BAY AREA.
I'D LIKE TO SAY THAT IN ORDER
TO REALIZE THE PROMISE OF THE
PRISON CLOSURE STATEWIDE THERE
MUST BE EXTENSIVE LABOR
TRANSITION PLANS THAT ARE NOT
ONLY INCLUDED INCLUDE THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE EMPLOYED AT CDC
ARE IN THE PRESENT BUT ALSO.
CREATING JOBS FOR PEOPLE THAT
ARE RELEASED AND PEOPLE LIVING
IN THE PRESENT TOWNS. WE NEED
CAREERS THAT HE'LL NOT HURT THE
COMMUNITY. TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
INDIVIDUALS RELY ON THE INCOME
GENERATED FROM- THE SYSTEM IN
CALIFORNIA AND UNHEALTHY
INCARCERATION SYSTEM MUST AN-
UNDERSTANDING THAT HEALTHY
EMPLOYMENT IS LIFE SAVING.
EFFORTS TO TRANSITION PEOPLE
INTO JOBS THAT BENEFIT EVERYONE
IN THE COMMUNITY IS VITAL AND
WE CANNOT HARM THOSE WHO ARE
MOST MARGINALIZED. THE FUNDING
SHOULD BE MOVED INTO HOW TO
HELP LABOR TRANSITION INTO
THESE POSITIONS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS IN THE QUEUE. OKAY
THANK YOU TO EVERYONE THAT
PARTICIPATED IN THE- PUBLIC
COMMENTS IN THE PALACE AND THE
MEMBERS THIS MEANS THE TURNED.
BUT.